Now as a journalist when you see shit
like that that has got to hit home.
Oh yeah. The last few years for,
for journalist, especially if your,
I mean he wasn't an American citizen,
but he did write for the Washington
Post and was a resident. But,
but I mean I was, I was, I was
arrested in Iran for a week, a long,
long time ago and roughly the same time
and Iranian Canadian photographer was
arrested and she was
raped and beaten to death.
So the people that are citizens of
these countries there, they're really,
really bearing the brunt. Um, and again,
that's why I'm uncomfortable if people
call me brave because I get to come home
with these guys,
you know,
they can get to them and they can get
to their families very easily. And that,
that takes a whole other level of bravery.
And the woman who was raped and beaten
to death, what was she involved with?
What happens? Photographer. She was
just taking pictures of, yeah. Yeah.
And the usual thing with, I
mean, certainly we in Iran,
but this is common all over the place.
Um,
if you're a dual citizen working
as a journalist in for example,
around they'll accuse you of being a spy.
I was accused of being a spy.
They tried to get me to
confess to being a spy.
That's a very normal assumption out there.
And how long were you in jail for?
Just seven or eight days. He was
out like actually not, not too bad.
I mean psychologically it was bad
because they were threatening torture and
execution. Um, physically it wasn't,
it wasn't too bad. I was fed. Um,
I had a bad bed that was roughed up
a bit. I wasn't, I wasn't beaten. Um,
but I did think it could last months
and months and months and I did think I
could go to Evin prison.
They actually put me in a car and drove
me to what they said was ever in prison
once and then just took me somewhere else.
Evan prison,
even prisoners where people
have been tortured and executed.
So they just drove you there are scarier.
Drove me around for a few hours to scare
me and then took me to another place
here. What were they trying to get
you to confess to the being a spy?
And they said, at one point they said, uh,
do you honestly expect us to believe
you travel the world collecting all this
information and you don't share it
with your government? I said, yeah,
that's exactly how it works.
And they thought I was insulting
their intelligence by, by saying that.
What were you over there
covering? We were, I did a series.
One of the first series I did was
called holidays in the access of evil.
So I spent my first four years as a
journalist undercover wearing a secret
camera.
And Luckily I appeared on a couple of
docs with the guy who was not very good.
And so I looked genuine next to him.
Um,
so the control to BBC Two said,
give this guy a series.
And I was racking my
brains trying to think.
I wanted to be a foreign correspondent
and wanting to cover conflict than George
Bush made the axis of evil speech.
And John Bolton added three countries
to the list. So it was Iraq, Syria,
Cuba, and North Korea. Uh, Libya,
Cuba with a six evil countries.
So we went to all six countries.
Me and one camera man held
out handheld camera chain,
actually saw it and that's
when he first reached out.
And I started talking to vice
about eventually joining them,
but kind of documentaries from the
streets up to, we're just trying to say,
you know,
despite all the rhetoric about Iran,
this is what the people are actually like.
And it was, it was kind of youth led.
We,
we interviewed a bunch of students who
are involved in some famous protests in
1999 where the police came in and smashed
the dormitory and burned them down and
beat them.
I think because we interviewed them,
we were then tracked in and arrested.
Oh, so how'd you get it free?
How did I get, how'd you get free?
Uh, it's, I didn't know at the time,
but if to come 10 countries
have diplomatic relations.
It's only a big deal after a week.
So on the night of the seventh day or the,
or the eighth day, they, they let
me go. Oh yeah. But I had no idea.
At the time. I thought, I thought
this could go on months and months.
A month now when you were over there in
around what is their perception of the
United States when you're talking to
the young people over there? Oh, uh,
love the United States real music culture,
sports,
everything and over extremely well
educated about the United States. Um,
American foreign policy is a completely
different discussion, but I mean,
one of the things we tried to cover was
the Friday rally at Tehran University
where you see everyone
chanting death to America,
death to Israel and we wanted to cover
it because they bus in old men from the
countryside who sent their guy. Yeah.
Death to America. Death to Israel. Real.
It's not something to be seeking
some propaganda. Staged event. Yeah.
I mean if there was a turning point in
the Iraq and Afghanistan wars and with
Iran, Ryan Crocker, who was the
former ambassador to Saudi Arabia,
Israel, Iraq, Afghanistan,
s straight off the nine 11,
he was sent to Geneva where a number of
countries affected by the refugee crisis.
We're meeting to discuss
how to deal with it.
One of the countries that are wrong,
so that have this meeting.
And then he and his Iranian
counterpart would disappear for,
he says seven or eight hours over tee
to discuss the future of American Iran
relations. They knew that they were
going to get rid of the Taliban. Um,
so the Uranian said, okay, here's
a map of the Taliban leaders homes.
If you take out those homes on day one,
Taliban have finished and Ryan
Crocker set up, thank you. Can I,
can I take notes from this map? They said,
the map is yours. We made it for you.
Gave him the map. Uh, let the
Americans use Iranian airspace,
handed over some prisoners.
They were absolutely key in us
overthrowing the Taliban so quickly.
And Ryan Crocker was making good progress.
And then talking about the future of
Iraq post Sudan one night he gets a knock
on his door. [inaudible] and two of his
staff has come in and say, boss, you'll,
you'll really not kind of like
what's just happened. And he said,
what's just happened?
And it was the axis of evil speech.
So the moderate so-called in Iran who
had fought hard to get permission to
negotiate with the Great Satan, the
u s said, you've made us look stupid.
You know, it was hard for us to get this
chance. We helped you in Afghanistan.
We were willing to discuss future
relations between our two countries and,
and this is, this is what
happens. So it's over why.
And then fairly soon after that,
obviously there's the invasion of Iraq
and Iran is sponsoring the insurgency and
giving them sophisticated ids and
all that rather than, you know,
potentially helping.
So you think that with wow,
with one speech.
Yeah, the whole thing
shifted. Yeah. So they would,
they would've been willing to somehow
or another negotiate or cooperate or I
mean at work alongside getting rid of
sedan was obviously an in their interests.
You know, they put a brutal eight
year that year were with it.
We have a very strange
relationship with Iran. I mean,
going back to the hostages
from the Jimmy Carter era. Yep.
I buy, I do think it's one of the most
misunderstood countries in the region.
I mean, when you actually
go there, um, you know,
that people are so smart and so
educated and, and potentially such,
such good allies. So what is the
key issue? It's the government.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
And you know what I just explained and
I think they're capable of thing being
far more rational than,
than the speeches by the crazy odd
mullahs what would suggest, Huh?
They proved it.
Yeah.
And the idea that the Saudis and Mrr teas
can somehow bomb the WHO sees in Yemen
into submission and push back Iranian
influence on their southern border is,
is ridiculous. That's just
never going to happen. Um, and,
and I think even if you ignore
the obvious moral argument, um,
just from a pragmatic point of view,
the idea that we should back this, um,
unconditionally is, is
ridiculous. Let's see.
This is just part of the real problem
when you're dealing with world advanced,
is trying to parse all this stuff out and
look at so many different stories from
so many different parts of the world
in so many different areas of conflict.
And it's almost impossible to
pay attention to it all. Yeah.
Every time I meet people from
these countries, I'm, I, I'm,
I feel like a fraud because there's so
much that they know that I don't know and
I shouldn't. Right. Um, and you know,
I get paid to do this and I get paid to
pay attention to this for a living and I
feel out of my depth regularly and that's
focusing on the five or six countries
that I focused on,
let alone everything else.
What other countries do
you focus on? Uh, I mean,
the last few years has been Congo
quite a bit. Afghanistan, mostly Iraq,
Yemen, I focused on a lot of
the last three, four years.
Um, they're the main ones.
I've been to Brazil recently, been to
Central African Republic recently that,
but Nah.